when is next Quinn is in New York hi
Quinn how are you hi David thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up okay so my husband and I
are 23 and just got married in September
congratulations I've been working thank
you so much so I've been working
full-time for a little over a year and
he has six more months of home he
graduates from undergrad and I grew up
listening to you thanks to my mom and I
followed your plan to what we called
your principles to achieve so before I
got married I was on baby step 4
my question comes in so my husband has
14,000 921 dollars in student loans
should we just and we've obviously
combined bank accounts everything so
should we just empty our emergency fund
down to $1,000 to kind of pay off about
half of the loans yep you were on baby
step four when you got married he took
you back to baby step two right okay so
now we are one in print recession now
you are one totally and you combined
your bank accounts but you you know it's
just hard for you and I don't blame you
because you were riding along pretty
good and I'm sure he's worth it but you
married into some bad think the main
thing is just like since we're only on
one paycheck right now for the next
month no same thing you know so what is
he yeah I mean this is he's working his
undergrad right degree in cyber security
what is she studying cyber oh that's
wonderful what a great career field and
so what brings him from working while
he's getting his degree so he's actually
in ROTC right now he's going to be going
to the Army Reserve so that takes a lot
of time and they do pay him like a
stipend every two weeks and you have
some scholarships coming in not taking
it anymore alone it's just from before
okay so he does he is creating some
income and he is working he's not just
going to school so um that's good all
right good let's just let's roll up our
sleeves put our budget together with our
current situation you know the great
news is in twelve months from today your
world's going to be completely different
with both of you kicked into gear and
he's got a great career field y'all are
gonna be making Bank also okay
so much you are heading in the right
direction very very well done